okay so we got the episode avatar day
and boy was I off about what I thought
this one was gonna be about I thought
this was just from the title I thought
was gonna be a retread of that one
episode where he's praised and lets it
go to his head
not even close man and I again I love
those surprises instead I got an episode
that honestly I think it we think such
out the storm so far this is my favorite
episode because I really feel like I've
been on like a roller coaster it's funny
because it's not one of those that's
extremely focused on a lot of story
going on but they throw so much at you
but it's never too much it's just the
right balance as the right balance of
story it's the right balance of
character it's the right balance of
comedy it's the right balance of drama
and it does go into furthering the story
as well and also and also furthering
more about what we know about the
characters and what they be willing to
do and how far they can be pushed and it
all just works so great and for the most
part there's a lot comedy in this one
that this is the one where Aang goes to
an earthbending village again trying to
learn how to Earthbend a finds out about
this something called avatar day where
they think it's a celebration like when
I said before but instead it's a day
where all the villagers come together
and they burn the statues of the past
avatars because while the reincarnations
apparently killed I forgive it's a
general or one of their leaders but it
killed someone very important to them
you know so some hundred years ago and
egg sees this as hey as one of the
reincarnation Zhai have the right to
defend myself and we'll look into this
because what do we really know about
this this does not sound like something
one of my reincarnations would do so
they agree but they say you have to
abide by our rules and Aang kind of
foolish Willy goes along with it but
again if they're honorable and I really
admire that but they don't know these
rules are gonna be so bad crazy and
so you have Sokka and Katara's
are going to look for evidence to prove
that he's innocent
while he's put in this prison I
in these shackles that the first thing I
say is you know I think he can get out
of that and sure enough as he's talking
these are prisons he just slits out and
sort of leans on top of it and on top of
that you have the sack is trying to do
all this research and it's it's funny
it's it's funny because it this is
something that I felt against are
opening up an old wound for some people
but something I think district 9 missed
they're doing a satire obviously of
Sherlock Holmes you have him with a pipe
a heaven with a hat you haven't with
this little magnifying monocle it
obviously is supposed to be Sherlock
Holmes but the reason it works and the
reason it is so funny is because it
still works in that world if you didn't
know who Sherlock Holmes was you would
still laugh at how hard he's trying to
solve this case and the fact that the
stuff is still practical he has the
sword dragon pipe it blows bubbles but
he does it to try and look more
sophisticated he has this hat because
there's a magnifying monocle on top of
it so it works even if you don't know
who you're like Holmes is if you do know
who Sherlock Holmes is it's even funnier
because obviously they're doing a satire
of this except it's knocking the rolls -
Sherlock Holmes and he's putting sister
out of the way you're trying to solve it
and that's incredibly funny and that's
why la si has set some district 9 didn't
work because the the satire and the very
obvious commentary are they don't exist
in that world they only exist as a means
to push this commentary and this still
works in its world that's why the comedy
in this one is so good it is so funny
but on top of that you also have great
stuff with uh with Zuko and the uncle
who split ways in this episode and it's
not obvious they're gonna do that and
it's a it's a hard split it's it's
really difficult and it's again it's
another you can do Co the one who
initiates it and you can kind of see him
doing it you could you can see it
happening but you wouldn't predict it
and again that's
a great surprise from a character and
this episode has so many great surprises
it and great twists in it you have this
predicament where Sokka and Katara's are
trying to prove Aang's innocence but
then you have this twist that the king
of this earth nation just wants to the
way it works is that he just decides he
there's no real evidence he just decides
what he feels he wants to do it even if
it's not right or wrong uh some great
commentary in there in my opinion about
about certain laws and and justice and
stuff in America so I mean I screw
America all over the world this happens
I mean there's things that aren't fair
but some people just want it because
it's what they want and I like this
episode kind of addresses that and they
won't even look at the evidence they
won't even hear it or think about it um
so that's great but then there's another
great twist when they're trying to prove
a existence but it turns out the
reincarnation did kill this one person
but then there's another twist and how
exactly it happened because the person
was a tyrant and it wasn't necessarily
on purpose that this guy was killed she
tried to get away but then but through a
crack that she caused separating these
two nations which is an awesome scene by
the way the way she splits it it's
really cool we also have we have him
falling off because he stayed there
which is technically her fault and she
still takes responsibility for it and
sure enough they spin this wheel of
torture whatever it was and he's gonna
be boiled in oil or something and but
then at the last minute the Fire Nation
comes in and again Aang's gonna stick to
his punishment again very honorable
thing to do and if they want to save the
day you know I'm gonna be boiled in oil
what can you do and the guy turns the
wheel a little bit more it says haha
community service you serve the
community by stopping the Fire Nation
here so that all these little twists and
all these developments and new surprises
like I said it's the first time we
actually saw to kyoshi is that he said I
forget even get the name wrong uh
her coming into Ang's a character you
know they're taking on her form in his
body I mean was a legit shot I mean
every time that happens they use that
just the right time because I didn't
even know he could do that or or she
could take over the body like that I
sort of assumed it was just this one guy
like the last one but I it shows now
that any of them can and so there's nice
little surprises like that it's also
good to know that these reincarnations
will come in when it's really needed and
this is needed not just for aang but
it's needed to set the record straight
on history on something that has caused
this really great prejudice and this is
sort of this destruction of a good name
even if parts of it were true so there's
great twist in this one there's great
energy in this one this one is just
constantly moving and constantly
throwing stuff at you but it's not all
story it's a lot of characters it's a
lot of environment it's you know and it
is a lot plot too and but it also has
slow moments like I said the moments
with Zuko and the uncle are very
effective and they're very good he
finally see what happens with the the
blues spear coming in how did he get
that costume by the way he's blown out
of the airship or the night the airship
the the the Fire Nation ship which is
now submarine I got that wrong sorry
they look like submarines but he's blown
out of there did he just grab the blue
spirit out Finn the masks and everything
when he was shot out of there so I don't
know but I'm like he has this costume
and he's using it to rob and the uncle
doesn't know about it and again the Zuko
realizes he has to split ways because
I've got it for a number of reasons
probably it could be he doesn't he knows
their ideologies are very different and
I think Zuko thinks that's going to slow
him down and he really appreciates his
uncle but he can't be slowed down he has
to he feels he has to find his own path
as well and I think he appreciates his
uncle's help but he needs that space
very true of you know a teenage boy
growing up so but it's a hard split and
it's very
dramatic and I was shocked for all the
comedy that's in this very good comedy
and very fast comedy how strong the
dramatic moments were when when the
other avatar comes and takes over Aang's
body when Zuko has to split from his
uncle I mean these are strong moments in
the very poignant moments but at the
same time it's so it's so quick in in
the other moment but I guess these are
moments it keeps it so slow and quiet
and calm and it's a perfect balance and
it's so rare that I see that that they
can throw so much comedy but also so
much drama something like the storm it
is mostly drama and you need that but
this was the first episode I saw where I
was like wow this is just like perfect
like a really perfect balance of
everything I say if I had to nitpick the
only two problems I had was this is just
a style thing the when a character can
go like from here suddenly like two back
there in a jump cut yet for the sake of
comedy I get it it's it's just awkward
to me unless it's really used at a
perfect moment but like when Sokka is
investigating suddenly he's here then
suddenly he's back here with any cheer
and he's looking at this and I don't
know it's like I need a you know I need
a smear cut there is a you know I need
to see a little bit of the movement if
you're gonna do that it has to be at a
very funny moment he's just looking
around doesn't do much for me and then
the only other thing I'll talk about is
you know the foaming mouth guy it's a
magic that could only be done once and I
know probably everybody loved it and
they felt they should do it again
because it got such a big laugh and
kudos you want to bring back something
that a lot of people liked and you even
do a variation but it's it was such a
special moment in comedy it can't be
replicated I appreciate the effort but
Matt you just can't do but the first
time was so funny so those are the
tiniest of nip fakes but again being a
comedian I like to talk about calm
so yeah I really enjoyed this episode
greatly a probably like I said my second
favorite probably to the storm even
though there's more dramatic episodes
and episodes that even have heavier
stuff I would argue I just I felt like
like I said it was just a rush of stuff
and it was so much fun and it was so
funny and then when the dramatic moments
happened they were really shocking and
they had good twists that surprised me
and I was I was in every single moment
it gave me when it wanted to make me
laugh it made me laugh what I wanted to
make me be invested the characters I got
invest in the characters when it I went
why me deserve here this subtle
commentary I was hearing the subtle
commentary everything it was trying to
do it accomplished so as I said even
though it's probably not one of the
heaviest dramatic ones I think
everything it wanted to hit it pretty
much hit a bull's-eye with so I really
really enjoy this episode so yeah that's
about it and I will see you at the next
episode again a really great one